recent college grads finding that their
nine to fives aren't getting the job
done when it comes to paying their bills
many turning to gig work to supplement
their entry level salary incomes with a
growing platform
probably in the last two months we've
seen an exponential rise in all of our
markets alex atwood is the ceo and
founder of gravywork an online platform
that connects thousands of workers with
flexible and part-time hourly jobs
through a mobile app a service outward
says is booming with 20 times more
weekly applicants using the platform
than ever before
college students and recent college
graduates needing to supplement their
income with various jobs and hospitality
warehouse operations and retail
merchandising
gig economy and gives accessibility to
those
people who want to do things outside of
just ride sharing or grocery delivery so
you could literally go to your local
coffee shop if they're on the gravy work
platform and you can pick shifts up
there at a premium atwood says it pays
higher because employers are finding it
more difficult to backfill a position
due to vacation time or sick time
creating a great opportunity and
flexibility for the hourly worker it's
really up to the employee or the worker
now in in terms of um in terms of the
power shift and and and that's and
that's a good thing for companies like
ours and and it's great for college
students who have so much access now